one of the themes of the 2016
presidential election was that Donald
Trump would endlessly repeat that the
scandal is Hillary Clinton's emails the
disqualifier for Hillary Clinton as
president was that she did not handle
email securely she was careless with
sensitive and secret information because
of this email server that she had she
must be investigated at nauseam forever
and she needs to be locked up which
trump actually said would happen under
his administration during the campaign
immediately after being elected said
actually that that's not going to really
be a priority of my administration and
what I am here to tell you today that if
Hillary Clinton's emails deserved an
investigation Donald Trump's current
iPhone use as president deserves ten
investigations in the last 24 hours
we've learned something totally
unsurprising but still horrifying which
is that Donald Trump is shunning all
security advice and using at least two
iPhones regularly regularly and isn't
allowing the iPhone that he uses for
internet use to be scanned for hacking
attempts and cyber attack threats
because it is quote not convenient for
him he's got at least two iPhones that
we know about one can only make calls no
data on that phone the other is for his
internet use posting to Twitter who
knows what else he's doing on the
internet and Trump is refusing to have
his Twitter phone checked for hacking
attempts President Obama
you might recall had his blackberry
taken away when he was president because
of the security risk these phones are
prime targets not just for your
run-of-the-mill hackers but for foreign
intelligence agencies and Obama when his
blackberry was taken away was given a
phone with no microphone no camera no
GPS it was screened once a month for
security concerns the entire case
against Hillary Clinton's email server
was it's not a secured and approved
government system period Donald Trump's
iPhone is not an approved and secured
government system James Comey said
Hillary Clinton was careless in her use
of that email server Donald Trump's
behavior is the epitome of
carelessness and he was slamming Hillary
for a private non-governmental email
server he's using a private
non-governmental iPhone and at least
Hillary Clinton's email server was set
up with some professional security
protocols and Trump slammed Hillary for
negligence when it came to her emails
Donald Trump is literally neglecting the
security imperatives that his staff is
presenting to him and saying we've got
to get that phone checked because it's
not convenient for him and you know if
if Trump wasn't regularly doing
monumental things on that phone we might
be able to make a different argument
although I don't think so but Trump's
tweets move the stock market they can
create or solve geopolitical problems
they dictate news headlines and he's
sending the tweets out from an unsecured
iPhone that he will not have checked for
breach attempts because apparently
national security is not convenient for
Donald Trump hey guys I'm starting to
think that maybe Republican outrage over
Hillary's emails might not have been all
about data security Pat is that at all
possible I mean it would definitely be a
big deal if Donald Trump's
communications got hacked
but if you think about it like the Trump
administration has been playing scandal
whack-a-mole for the entire time that
they've been in office so you have the
Russia stuff give the stormy Daniel
stuff you have like pay to play and his
whole cabinet is a mess of corruption so
I don't know if this ranks in the top
ten or so but it just puts everything in
context because the Republican argument
was that Hillary Clinton is not
qualified to be president because she
can't keep her communications secure you
can make the same argument now against
Donald Trump and yeah it's home that's
why it's a big deal because this was the
reason you shouldn't have voted for
Hillary write it this was the reason why
she was disqualified according to
Trump's narrative from being President
of the United States and I've got to
tell you something else
the idea that people might be trying to
hack into Trump's iPhone it's not some
spy movie fantasy because the Department
of Homeland Security has detected mobile
phone surveillance devices in Washington
DC and they don't know who they belong
to this was reported early last month
and we've talked about these devices
called
stingray and police will sometimes use
stingray devices at protests to
eavesdrop on the phone communications of
protesters the Department of Homeland
Security found stingray type devices
which are generally called cell tower
simulators in Washington DC and they
weren't able to tie them to any
particular local or federal law
enforcement agency or operation they've
identified them they're there but it's
not clear who's actually using those
nothing matters anymore and this is why
we need to vote them out in 2018 and
Pat's write that this is not even going
to rank for the long list of scandals
that the administration's been involved
in I can only be a broken record about
this until November and I'm warning you
as it's a heads up I'm going to be a
broken record about this until November
the only way to deal with the hypocrisy
the swamp filling corruption the
terrible policy ideas everything that
we're talking about there's one way
right now which is to actually go out
and vote in November of 2018 and I hope
that you will do that send me your
thoughts am I missing something about
how the exact same thing that Donald
Trump is doing is what he identified as
the disqualifying actions of Hillary
Clinton during the campaign I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
twitter at david pakman show today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by Cody a new innovative
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that's setting out to
revolutionize how payments are sent and
received online what Cody stands for is
currency of the internet and most
Kryptos out there today simply weren't
designed for online payments and the
goal of the Cody crypto is to achieve an
infrastructure for online payments that
simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous and scalable which no
blockchain for payments has really
achieved to date so Cody is aiming to be
that missing piece of the puzzle a
crypto and platform actually designed
with online payments in mind if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about Cody
and their ICO by using the links below
the video this
is not financial advice and should not
be interpreted as such and everybody
should do their own research on any
project that they're interested in